we spent a lot of time thinking about
things about things yeah in terms of
making him a real character and giving
emotional sounds ridiculous emotional
complexity and but it shows and the way
he yeah yeah and he does things you know
what sort of like
yeah the perplexity yeah
you can release the stabbing of the yeah
no that's one of the most emotional
moments in there yeah you'd like if on
paper you'd be like um I don't know is
that right well that wasn't gonna work
and that was we agreed like uh how is it
gonna work so it's one of those which
we'd like to do is like to take a risk
in terms of like you have no idea if
it's gonna walk and it could be the
cheesiest there's a rubber hand uh you
know stab to the wall why should you
give a [__] but
but it's like yeah so that's one of the
things and we had this amazing crazy
Romanian magician what's his name his
name's Victor dormant but we did all
these editions for a thing as well so
all these people come in and it was the
three of us and Tim uh and they were all
performing and then Tim would be doing
his do you ever do that yeah yeah Tim
would be like Tim was really engaged in
the hand movements and he'd get on the
floor and and it was like giving lime
readings to a hand like Tim would get
down it was hilarious did you uh
the guy what's his name again Victor
Victor did Victor ever just like
sometimes you caught him like stretching
his hand so Victor had a a glove because
it was it was colds there was some sort
of big like like
warming glove thermal like yeah look
look like look like a kitchen like a
mitt like you wear to keep his hand nice
and warm yeah yeah I mean he could
probably after this series go to
conventions inside autographs he already
is yeah I'm surprised you haven't run
into him